you know what must be done Sabrina claim  the throne save precious Greendale your  boyfriend  [Music]  you can't keep going on like this it  can't be all how all the time seduce a  purpose it's not all hell it's all Nick  the balance is off in hell  so it's off in heaven so it is off on  earth to preserve one realm you must  preserve them home embrace your destiny  Sabrina hell's under new management you  sure you want to do this where you help  me here we go again  [Music]  if you want the crown going to have to  prove yourself well that's my girl  being queen of hell isn't a summer job  you're putting the coven in peril just  so you can see your boyfriend  forget about me you [ __ ] up into safe  safe Greendale my family my friends  everything I love  [Applause]  all right let's finish this  [Music]  honestly first / guitar now hell  [Music]  you